to trailer for the new Ant-Man and the
WASP has leaked and has given us our
first look and tease at Modoc let me
quickly show you the clip now
so unfortunately it's only a very very
quick tease and we don't really get to
see the best look at him but after fans
do get a glimpse at him at audience
cheers
to judging by the audience reaction I
would say his look does look pretty good
but it's hard to know about seeing it
for ourselves so if you guys didn't know
Modoc is a character from the Marvel
Comics and his name is actually an
Ackerman and it stands for mental orgasm
designed only for killing so I'm really
excited to see him in this film and
we'll also get to see Kang in his film
so this film just has a lot going for it
a judging by the rest of the trailer
which I've seen which unfortunately I
can't show you it looks like it's going
to be a much much darker film than what
from what we have seen from the previous
Airman films anyway guys that's about it
for this video so if you did enjoy this
video please like And subscribe to show
your support thanks for watching